اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
الدبلوماسيه روسيا تقصف البنا التحتيه
لاوكرانيا وتصعيد على الحدود مع بيلاروسيا
نتنياهو يستعيد السلطه في اسرائيل على
راسي حكومه من اقصى اليمين ونووي ايران
على راسي اولوياته
الفنانات الايرانيات وياخذنا موجه دعم
للاحتجاجات ورئيسه وزراء ايطاليا تدعو
لعدم التسامح مع حمله القمه
مجموعه السبع تطالب وحكومه الطالبان
بالتراجع فورا عن قراراتها ضد النساء وثلث
السكان معرضون لخطر المجاعه
ايه ده المشاهدين هنبدا من الملف
الاوكراني استيقظ سكان عده مدن اوكرانيه
على السلسله ضربات روسيه جديده ضربات
استهدفت البناء التحتيه وايضا مرافق
الطاقه في عز الشتاء القارس في مدينه
الفيف ادت الضربات الى حرمانه 90% من اهل
المدينه من الكهرباء هذا ويعاني 40% اصلا
من سكان العاصمه كليب من انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي ما دعى السلطات لحتى السكان
لشحنه هواتفهم تاهبا للانقطاع الذي قد
يطول بالانتقال الى مناطق دينيبرو واوديسا
وكريفيرا قالت السلطات انها قطعت الكهرباء
طبعا لتقليل الاضرار بمرافق البناء
التحتيه الحيويه في حاله قصفها بحسب مصادر
محليه اوكرانيه اطلقت روسيا بالفعل اكثر
من 100 و20 صاروخ تجاهها مواقع مختلفه عبر
البلاد من بينها مدينه نيكول وسومي اضافه
طبعا الى اكياس التي سجلت اصابته ثلاثه
اشخاص على اقل طبعا بحسب المسؤولينا
الاخرانين من يضبط وليس سيجذبوا هجوره
كرسوني
اسم يوسف
[موسيقى]
جسم اسود
هذا وابهرت الصور لجوء سكان العاصمه كيف
الى محطات المترو طبعا هربا من الضربات
الروسيه دعونا والتابعه
[موسيقى]
هذا واقيلا مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي جزء بوارير قال ان
جرائم الحرب التي ترتكبها روسيا في
اوكرانيا لن تمر دون حساب وفي تغريده له
قال ابو ريل ان روسيا شنت هجوما صاروخيا
واسعا نطاق ضد اوكرانيا دمر على نحو
عشوائي البنا التحتيه والمرافق الطبيه
واستهدف وقتل مدنيين وراء الاضافه ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي مستمر في دعم اوكرانيا
بمنتهى القوه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المزيد مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل اهلا بيك
حذيفه صحيح كما تذكر المعلومات هناك قصف
مكثف من قبل الروس ولكن بالمقابل المضادات
يقال بانها رده طبعا مضادات الاوكرانيه
ردت وبقوه كيف يمكن ان نقص الوضع
تحياتي ميسون النسبه بلغت ااا 78 اييي في
المئه نسبه ااا ااا اسقاط الصواريخ
الروسيه التي اطلقت نحو الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اطلق بحسب فاليري زولوجي وهو
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
64 صاروخا واسقط الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني
54 صاروخ هنا في العاصمه كيف طبعا كان
نصيب كيف 16 صاروخا من القصف في مناطق
متفرقه وتم اسقاط جميع الصواريخ التي وجهت
نحو مدينه اكيف هنالك بعض الشضايا في
منطقه سقطت وتضرر احد المنازل في بتشيلسي
ايضا سقط سقط شظايا وتضرع احد وتضرر احد
المنازل وكذلك منشاه صناعيه انا الان في
هذه القريه الصغيره وهي في ضواحي العاصمه
حيث سقط صاروخ سقط صاروخ روسي هنا في هذه
المنطقه اذا تبعتي معي في الصوره هنا عمال
الكهرباء يعملون على عادت التيار وعلى وضع
هذا العمود الذي كان هناك عمود يعني غيره
في هذا المكان وايضا هذا العمود دمر وسقط
بسبب الضربه الصاروخيه اذا انتقلنا الى
الداخل هنا على على يسار الشاشه يوجد هذه
المنازل التي دمرت بشكل كبير هنا حيث سقط
الصاروخ هذا المنزل كان يعيش فيه اربعه
اشخاص ولسخريه القدر ميسون هؤلاء الاشخاص
الاربعه هم من النازحين من مدينه ماريوبيل
ظنه طبعا انهم يمكنهم اللجوء الى هذه
القريه الصغيره في ضواحي العاصمه اكيد
ولكن ال- ال- ال- الصواريخ الروسيه لاحقت
بهم حتى هنا في بدايه الامر السكان
والجيران هنا لم يكونوا يعلمون اذا كانوا
بالداخل ام لا لذلك عمال الانقاذ عملوا في
هذا المنزل وليستر طويله للبحث عنهم ولكن
لم يجدوا اي احد تحت الانقاط هذه الحفره
التي سقط فيها الصاروخ الذي نتيجه كان هذا
الدمار الهائل هذا المنزل وفي المنازل
المجاوره اذا نظرنا الى ايضا هذا المنزل
الذي اتضرر بشكل كبير هنا طبعا كان يسكن
الجد وااه ابنته وحفيدته الذين نقلوا الى
المستشفى هم المصابين الثلاثه
نعم طبعا الضرر اصابه يعني القصف لم يصف
فقط العاصمه كيف ولكن ايضا مدينه الفيفا
التي 90% من المدينه الان دون كهرباء كذلك
مدينه اوديسا ايضا تعاني اسقط 21 او تم
تدمير 21 صاروخ همم من الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني في سماء مدينه اودسيا همم عصومي
لصواريخ الى الدنيا التحتيه في هذه المدن
ولكن طبعا تم تسجيل اربعه صواريخ في مدينه
كف وكذلك قطعت الكهرباء
وتدميره للصواريخ
في الحقيقه الجديد بالفعل ميسون هو قدرته
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني على
امكانيه تدمير الصواريخ الروسيه
واستهدافها بل حتى بلغت النسبه كما قال لي
ريزولوجي
78% وهي نسبه تعتبر جيده جدا نسبه للمساحه
لحجم الاستهداف الذي حدث ايضا طبعا هذا
الاستهداف ياتي بعد ان بالامس القريفي
الليله الماضيه اعلن الاتحاد الروسي عن
انه يعني الحد الادنى لقبول عمليه التفاوض
هو اعتراف اي من المفاوضين في وكان
الاوكرانيين او الغربيين الاعتراف
بالمناطق الاربعه التي ضمها الاتحاد
الروسي ثم في الصباح الباكر هو يرغم كيف
وجميع المدن الاخرانيه طبعا هذا ايضا ياتي
بعد استقرار طفيف شهدته بعض المدن في همم
جدول القطاعات الكهرباء والان هذا
الاستهلاف سيعيد انا خطوات الى الورثه
شكرا ج لك على هذه المعلومات وهذه الصور
وقد اعترضت انظمه الدفاع في بيلاروسيا
صاروخا اوكرانيا من طراز 300 حيث اعلنت
منك ان حطام الصاروخ سقط على اراضيها وذلك
بالقرب من الحدود الاخرانيه وسائل اعلام
بيلاروسيه اكدت ان الرئيس اليكساندر
لوكيشنكو وجه الجهات المختصه بتحديد اسباب
السقوط قبل ذلك ذكرت الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه انها تراقب عن كتب الوضع في
بيلاروسيا على اساس اليوم وسط تقارير عن
تواجد اكثر من 10,000 جندي روسي على
الحدود بلا روسيه
هذا وقد اشرف الرئيس الروسي الذي ميرفوت
على بدء تشغيل سفن حربيه جديده حيث تعهد
بتعزيز قوه بلاده البحريه بوتن قال ان
بلاده ستقوم بتسريع وزياده حجم بناء السفن
من مختلف المشاريع وتجهيزها باحدث الاسلحه
واجراء التدريبات العملياتيه والقتاليه
باستخدام الخبره التي حصلت عليها موسكو
خلال العمليه العسكريه الخاصه طبعا في
اشاره الى الحرب في اوكرانيا شملت تدشين
الجديد الرادادا وكصحه الغامق
نوويه العابره للقرار
ومن جنبي جدد الرئيس الاوكراني سكي
مطالبات وشروط للدخول في مفاوضات للسلام
مع روسيا تنهي الحرب الا ان موسكو كما ذكر
مراسلنا رده بانك يير ليست جاهزه
للمفاوضات وان محاولاتها لدفع روسيا خارج
مناطق اوكرانيا هو وهم على حد طبعا تعبير
وزير الخارجيه سرجيله
على الارض ستكون اكبر من مكاسب التفاوض
وبينما يزداد الصراع الدمويه في البرد
القارس الذي لم يستطع التخفيف من حراره
الحرب يقترح المسؤولون من الطرفين خوضا
مفاوضات سلام الا ان مقابلتك كل منهما
لشروط الاخر لا تنم عن مدى جديه المقترح
محادثات السلام الوحيده التي جرت بين
الطرفين تزامنت مع بدايه الحرب حملت معها
شروط المحايده اما اليوم فتتمتع كيا في
موقفا اقوى يدفعها لزياده مطالبها
المتوافقه مع اثار الحرب المتزايده يوما
بعد يوم ليطرح الرئيس الاوكراني
خطط السلام مجددا متضمنه 10
اولها سحب القوات الروسيه ووقف العمليات
القتاليه وضمان العداله بمحاكمه مرتكب
جرائم الحرب بالاضافه لمنع تصعيد الصراع
وتقدي امانات حول ذلك لاوكرانيا وتاكيد
انتهاء الحرب من خلال توقيع وثيقه بين
الطرفين ولما كانت محطه زابوريج النوويه
اكبر المخاوف التي قد تسببك كارثه نوويه
تطالب كيف بضمان السلامه الاشعاعيه وفي
الخطه عادته وحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه بعد
ان وقعت روسيا قرار ضم اربعه اقاليم
اوكرانيه الى اراضيها بالاضافه الى
الافراج عن السجناء وامن الطاقه والامن
الغذائي وحمايه البيئه
لم يقبل بصيغه السلام المطروحه معتبرا
انكيف ليست جاهزه لخاض مفاضله سلام
نحن لا نرفض مقترحات للتوصل الى اتفاق
الدبلوماسي الشروط التي نحن مستعدون
بموجبها بدا المفاوضات معروفه جزء لا
يتجزا من هذه الشروط هو انتماء الاقاليم
الاربعه الى الاتحاد الروسي ضغوط اقتصاديه
ونفسيه ولوجستيه يعاني منها طرف الصراع
ويزيد الشتاء الطين بالله كلها ليست كافيه
بعد لدفع الطرفين الى تقديم بعض التنازلات
للجلوس على طاوله واحده
لانهاء حرب الاستنزاف الى عمر العربيه
رغم الحرب نحن لا نزال في اعياد هكذا عبرت
الصور حينما ظهر سانتا كلوز الروسي على
ظهره مدرعه في مدينه بلغراد الحدوديه مع
اوكرانيا وتجول بالاحياء في عربته للمصفحه
وتفاعل مع الجنود في احدى الغابات
جيليه
العاصفه الثلجيه في الولايات المتحده تقتل
60 شخصا نصفهم في مدينه بولاق
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ادت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه المنتميه لاقصى اليمين بقياده
بنيامين نتنياهو اليوم اليمين القانونيه
امام اعضاء الكنيسه مراسل العربيه افاد
بان احتجاجات خرجت في القدس تمديدا بحكومه
نتنياهو التي وصفت بالعنصريه من جانبه قال
نتنياهو امام البرلمان ان مهمته الاولى
تتمثل في منع ايران من تدمير اسرائيل
مشددا على ان تل ابيب ستعمل على احباط
مساعي انطلاق طهران اسلحه نوويه في وقت
سابقه عينا نتنياهو عضو اللي كود يوقف
جلانس وزيرا للدفاع ووزير الاستخبارات
السابقه الي كوهين وزيرا للخارجيه وشهدت
الجلسه اعتراضات داخل الكنيسه اثناء قراءه
نتنياه واسماء تشكيلته الحكوميه
بقى اربع سنين
عملوا من اجل ان تكون اسرائيل قوه عالميه
وتحقيقا لهذه الغايه يجب علينا احباط
تطوير الترسانه النوويه الايرانيه وتاكد
من ان ايران لن تمتلك قنابل ذريه والمهامه
الثانيه هي الاستمرار في توسيع دائره
السلام مع دول المنطقه وانهاء الصراع
العربي الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
ان ابدا بتشكيله هذه الحكومه وماذا تعني
لاسرائيل بنسبه لكم بحسب وجهت نظركم
شكرا لك يا استاذه ميسون على الاستضافه
تحياتي لكم ولجميع المشاهدين اا لا شك ان
هذه المره نحن لا نتحدث عن يمين ويسار
باسرائيل وانما عن معسكر المعسكر الموالي
اللي نتنيها والمعسكر المناهض له او ما
سمي بمعسكر التغيير ولماذا اقول هذا اقول
هذا لانه في معسكر التغير هناك احزاب
يمنيه كحزبك هذا الشعب الجديد برئاسه
جدا صار او حزب اسرائيل بيكون برئاسه اذا
نحن نتحدث هنا عن يمين وانما عن معسكر
المواليد شركه بانه هذا المعسكر الذي ليس
هو معسكر المتطرفا او متشددا او عنصريا
كما قالوا اينما يحتوي على عناصر صحيح
غايه في التشدد وانما هي اقليه داخل هذا
الائتلاف
ايضا من خلال الوعود التي قدمت يعني البعض
يتخوف بالداخل على ما يسمى بالديمقراطيطيه
اسرائيل على التعليم في الداخل الاسرائيلي
حتى على
مع اا فلسطينيه 48
ولكن لا شك فيه ان هناك التهديد هذه
الواضح على هويه اسرائيل على القيم
الصهيونيه الحركه الصهيونيه كان لديها قيم
واا فكره العلمانيه الفصل بين الدين
بالنسبه لكم
النظر الى المثليين العلاقه بين الدين
هناك
حاكم تحاول ان تعطي دوره الدين في السياسه
ربما يكونوا من المتطرفين الا انها ايضا
عرضت من خلال خطه الحكومه اليس كذلك
الخلافيه لم تعرض داخل الحوض في اطار حوض
خطوط الحكومه كانت هناك فقط دوليه كمان ان
نفصل بين خطط الحكومه وبين الدعاوي
الشعبويه الانتخابيه ادعوا الاشعبويه
والعبارات
الحقن تفوه بها عن سيد بينجي والسايس
موتشه لا يتقدس بصراحه لا تختلف كثيرا عن
العبارات التي تفوه بين الطالبين نت قبل
عامين قبل ان يصل الى سدد الحكم لذلك انا
اقول انه لا يجب ان يعول كثيرا على مثل
هذه
البركاندا الانتخابيه في نهايه المقاطع
مع الملف الفلسطيني
انا اعتقد انه
المساله القضيه عمليه السلام هي معطله منذ
زمن بعيد ولا اعتقد انه هناك اختلاف بشكل
بسبب تكوين الحكومه الحاليه
لاقتدام بقيه الاراضي ونيا لانهاء اتفاقيه
اوسلو كامله من خلال ضمن كل الامراض
الموجوده بالضفه بحسب ما ذكر
الحكم
هل فعلا هذا كذلك حينما قبل ان يصل الى
الحكم قبل عامين انا اعتقد انها مره اخرى
هذه العبارات الشعبويه لا يجب ان تبحث عن
الاعتبار
اسرائيل تستفيد من اخته كما يستفيد منها
الطرق الفلسطيني هي اا اساس العلاقه بين
القدس
ومن الذي يمكن ان يفعله نتنياهو لم يستطع
ان يفعله بالسابق انه ايضا تصريحات شعبويه
كما تذكر
الكبرى الاسرائيلي هناك توافق كامل داخل
طبقه فيها طبقه سياسيه في اسرائيل
كما انه رئيس المعارضه يلعب دورا ومحوريه
في القرارات الكبرى التي تتخذ في ما يتعلق
بالامن القومي من البلاد وبالتالي كان همم
يتم تشاور معه من قبل بنت في السابق و سوف
يتم تشاور هذه المره دقيقه رئيسا للمعارضه
في اي قرارات يتخذ وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه
في اسرائيل اجهزه امنيه حرقيه وهذه
الاجهزه لديها تقارير تصل الى الحكومه
تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار ولا اعتقد انه اللون
السياسي للحكومه سوف يؤثر على النهج
المتابعه خلال ازمه ايران النوويه
في الجامعه العبريه في القدس دكتور مائير
مصري كان معنا
قالت رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه
مع ايران المتظاهرين بما في ذلك اصدار
عقوبه الاعدام على بعضهم غير مقبول ولا
يمكن التهاون معه وقالت ميلوني في مؤتمر
صحفي بمناسبه نهايه العام ان ما يحدث في
ايران غير مقبول بالنسبه لهم ولم يعد
بامكاني ايطاليا التغاضي عنها اضافه انه
اذا لم تغير طهران موقفها فانا ايطاليا
ستتشاور مع الحلفاء لاتخاد اجراءات اكثر
فاعليه ضد النظام هناك
بلغت حصيله ضحايا الاحتجاجات الايرانيه
518 اشخاص بحسب ما افادت منظمه ارانا
لحقوق الانسان وذلك منذ بدء الاحتجاجات
المستمره في البلاد منذ مقتل الشاب
الكرديه مهسه امينه على يد قوه الشرطه من
بين الضحايا 66 قتيلا من قوات الامن كما
ذكر الموقع الحقوقي ان عدد القتلى تحت سن
18 بلغ 69 حاله كما قدر الموقع انه تم
اعتقاله اكثر من 18,000 شخص خلال هذه
الاحتجاجات منهم
667 من الطلاب
هذا هو مع استمرار الاحتجاجات في ايران
التي تجاوزت يومها المئه لا يزال الفنانون
وايضا صناع السينما الايرانيون يدعمون
الانتفاضه حيث تحدث الممثلات النظام
وظهرنا علنيه ومن دون حجاب اخر سلسله هذا
الدعم عبرت عنه الممثله الايرانيه ليلى
رشيد حيث كتب عبر حسابها على انستغرام
كتبت انها ستعبر عن رايها ونشرت صورتها
بلا حجاب لم تكن رشيد الوحيده التي عبرت
عن موقفها دعما للاحتجاجات ففي نوفمبر
الماضي نشرات ترنا علي دوستي صوره لها على
منصه انستغرام ايضا ظهرت فيها من دون حجاب
وحملت علي دوستي لافته كتب عليها نساء
وحياه وحريه هي جمله رافقت حركه الاحتجاج
التي اشعلها مقتل الفتاه الكرديه مساء
ميني طبعا على يد قوات الامن لاحقا اعتقلت
السلطات على دوستي واتهمتها بنشر الاكاديب
بسبب انتقادها اعدام المتظاهر الشاب محسن
شكاري عقبه ما قالت بانها محاكمه سريعه
وسريه وجهها فيها اتهامات من قبيل الافساد
في الارض كتبت حينها صمت الناس يعني دعمهم
للظالم والقمع هذا هو اعلنت لجنه متابعه
الفنانين الموقوفين نقلا عن عضوها مهدي
كوه يعني اعتقال نحو 40 فنانه قائمه تضم
150 شخصا تم استدعائهم او اتهامهم او
منعهم من المغادره او فرض قيود عليهم من
قبل المؤسسات المعنيه
لمواقفهم المسانده للاحتجاجات
اعلنت قوى الامن الداخلي التابعه لقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه مقتل احد عناصرها
واصابه اثنين اخرين في هجوم على طريق بين
مدينتي الرقه والحسكه قالت القوى في بيان
ان دوريه تابعه لها تعرضت لهجوم المسلح
على طريق الكرامه الواصل بين مدينتي الرقه
والحسد
وفي سياق اخر اكد وزير الدفاع التركي
خلوصي اكار خلال المحادثات التي جمعته
بنظره الروسي سردايش ويجو والسوري علي
محمود عباس اكد ان تركيا تحترم سياده
جيرانها بما في ذلك سوريا والعراق
اكدنا اننا نحترم وسلامه اراضي وسيادته
جميع جيراننا وخاصه سوريا والعراق هدفنا
الوحيد هو محاربه الارهاب وليس لدينا اي
غرض اخر شددنا على اهميه تحديد اعضاء
المنظمات الارهابيه
نقلت وسائل واعلام تونسيه عن الامين العام
للاتحاد العام للشغل نور الدين الطبوق
قوله ان الاتحاد لن يقبل بالفوضى ولي يسمح
بانهيار البلاد اضاف الطبوبي ان الاتحاد
سيقدم بمبادره مع مكونات المجتمع المدني
بعيدا عن التجاذبات السياسيه معتبرا ان
البلاد تعاني من اربع مشاكل بالاساس
قانونيه ودستوريه واقتصاديه واخرى
اجتماعيه
ارتفعت حصيله ضحايا العاصفه الثلجيه التي
تشهدها
الامريكيه لتبلغ 60 قتيلا فيما رشحت فرق
الطوارئ الرقم للارتفاع مجددا مع انحسار
الثلوج في غضون ذلك اكد عمده بافلو ان
المدينه الواقعه على الحدود الكنديه احصت
لوحدها 34 قتيلا فيما لا تزال اكثر من
1000 عائله من دون كهرباء في وقت سابق
اعلنت مصالح الارصاد الجويه انها تتوقع
انحسار العاصفه الثلجيه مع عوده درجات
الحراره للارتفاع نهار اليوم
[موسيقى]
في الخامسه ولاكن بعد قليل
مستثمرون لعملات المشفره يلجئون لبيع
اصولهم بالخساره لوقف نزيف خسائرهم
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه اغلقت جماعه
امور النسائيه في كابول ابوابها بالكامل
بعد قرار طالبان منع التعليم الفتيات
تعتبر هذه الجامعه جامعه مورق اول جامعه
نسائيه بالكامل من الموظفات والطلبه
والاساتذه وتندرج تحت مؤسسه مورا للتعليم
والتي تضم مدارس وجامعه ومراكز تدريب
واسكان للطالبات حيث تم افتتاحها عام 2016
وتضم ما يقارب من 550 طالبه في مختلف
التخصصات
قال المتحدث باسم اتحاد الجامعات الخاصه
في افغانستان محمد كريم نصيري اليوم قال
ان ربع الجامعات الخاصه في افغانستان
تواجه خطر لاغلاق بسبب الحظر المفروض على
الطالبات من قبل حكومه الطالبان اشار الى
ان هناك
25000 موظف جامعي مهددون بخساره وظيفتهم
بسبب القرارات مصير اضاف ان قرار طالبان
منعا تعليم الفتيات شامله 35% من اجمالي
طلاب الجامعه
مشاهدينا ننتقل الى هذه الصور المباشره
التي تاتينا لنتنياهو في ما يبدو بعد
مصادقه الكنيسه الاسرائيليه على تشكيله
حكومته الجديده طبعا هذه التشكيله التي
تعرضت لكثير من الانتقادات ان كان في داخل
الكنيسه او حتى في الخارج في الشارع بنت
وااه المعارضه هناك الاسرائيليه قالت
بانها لم تسمح بمثل هذه الحكومه التي
وصفوها بالحكومه اليمنيه المتطرفه بان
تستمر وسيتم همم تكون هناك محاولات لاسقاط
حكومه وصفت بانها من اقصى اليمين اذا هناك
مظاهرات ايضا خرجت في القدس احتجاجا على
هذه الحكومه في ما يراها الاسرائيليون
بانها تشكل تهديدا لما يسموه بالديمقراطيه
الاسره
هي خاصه في ظل ادخال عدد من التعديلات
والصلاحيات المتعلقه
بالوزرات والحقائب الرائعه الرئيسيه
على كل نعود الى كابول وقرار اغلاق
الجامعات او اغلاق احدى الجامعات مورا
وتوقع باغلاق المزيد من الش- الجامعات بعد
قرار همم طالبان منع الفتيات من الدراسه
من كابول تنضم الينا مؤمنه زاهد هي طالبه
جامعيه اهلا بك مؤمنه هل لك ان تعطينا
فكره عن تخصصك وتحصيلك العلمي اولا
ماين كرافت
اليس كذلك مؤمنه ماذا ستفعلين الان وكيف
تلقيتي قرار وقفه تعليم للطالبات
اممم
اكليب
على ذلك واغلاق ابواب الجامعات امام
الطالبات
لا استطيع فعل شيء
ولا استطيع ان نفعل ذلك
امل ولا نستطيع فعل اي شيء لذلك القرار
عندي كلاسطي يونيفرس
بالجامعات كنا نريد
[موسيقى]
الجامعات للطالبات
ولكنهم قالوا
انهم
[موسيقى]
يريدوننا
في بيوتنا امل امل
يتم فتح الجامعات
لكنني اشعر فعلا بالحزن
ولياس لان انا لن نستطيع فعل شيء طيب
مؤمنه ذكرتي انكم لا تستطيعون فعل شيء
بحسب الصور التي نشاهدها حتى الان على
الهواء مباشره هناك نوع من التظاهرات
وخروج النساء في الشارع اعتراض على مثل
هذه القرارات هي همم مقزمه هذه التحركات
ام انه هناك خطط للخروج حجم الدعم همم
الذي تحظى به المراه من الرجال في الشارع
في افغانستان تشعرين به او لا
كان يوم
[موسيقى]
ان تعيد السؤال سؤال يتعلق بتحركات
بالشارع شاهدنا بعض الصور للنساء فتيات
يخرجن في الشارع
للاعتراض احتجاجا على هذه القرارات هل
فعلا هناك مثل هذه التحركات ذكرت انكم لا
تستطيعون فعل شيء هل تستطيعون الخروج في
مثل هذه التظاهرات وماذا عن الرجال اهلك
بالبيت الى اي حد هناك دعم لكم للعوده او
تحركات معينه
اه بيكانتو
وورك
نحن نريد الحمايه
التعليم التعليم الثانوي والجامعات
امين امين
يجبروهم او يخبروهم ان عليهم
فرص العمل للمراه فالمراه الافغانيه لديها
مشكلات كثيره
[موسيقى]
اصبحت المراه غير قادره على ايجاد فرصه
عمل وهذه مشكله كبيره للنساء في افغانستان
ونامل ان يتم فتح ابواب الجامعه
وفرص العمل للمراه
من قبل كانت معنا مؤمنه زاهر طالبه جامعيه
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
السبع قد دعوا حركه الطالبان الى الغاء
العاجل لقرار عمل النساء في المنظمات غير
الحكوميه في افغانستان وفقا لبيان المشترك
نشرته وزاره الخارجيه البريطانيه اعرب
الدول عن قلقها من القرار الذي يعرض حياه
ملايين الافغان للخطر بسبب اعتمادهم على
المساعدات الانسانيه
هذا وبات اكثر من ثمانيه وعشرين مليون شخص
في افغانستان اي ما يقرب من ثلثي السكان
معرضينا لمخاطر المجاعه وايضا التدهور
الاقتصادي والفقر في اعقاب تصعيد حكومه
الطالبان ضد المراه وما تلاه من ادانات
دوليه واسعه كان اخرها تعليق منظمات
اغاثيه لاعمالها الامم المتحده اعلنت
ايقافه بعض برامج المساعدات بشكل مؤقت ردا
على حضر فردته طالبان على العاملات
الافغانيات في مجال الاغاثه والمنظمات
الاجنبيه غير الحكوميه الامم المتحده حذرت
من ان العديد من الانشطه الاخرى في طريقها
للتوقف في محاوله للضغط على الحركه التي
تتخذ قرارات وصفت بالله انسانيه ضد النساء
قال منسق المساعدات بالامم المتحده مارتن
درفتس ورؤساء وكالات تابعه للامم المتحده
ومنظمات اغاثه اخرى ان مشاركه المراه في
ايصال المساعدات غير قابل للتفاوض ويجب ان
تستمر داعين طالبان رجعوا عن قرارها وتؤكد
المنظمات الاغتيه انها لا يمكنها تجاهل
القيود التشغيليه التي تواجهها الان في
افغانستان حيث بات غير قادرين على اداره
برامجهم بدون موظفات
بدا موظفو قوات حرس الحدود في بريطانيا
جوله جديده من الاضطرابات المطالبه
بارتفاع الاجور وتحسين الظروف العمل في
العديد من المطارات البريطانيه بما في ذلك
مطر هيثروقات في لندن فيما لا تزال
الحكومه مصره على رفض مطالبه النقابات
بزياده الاجور لتعويض اثر التضخم مع
المرتفع وتتوقعات باستمرار الجوله الجديده
من الاضطرابات حتى ليله راس السنه
من جانبه يهدد الرئيس المقبل لمؤتمر
النقابات العمال في بريطانيا باتخاذه
اجراءات قانونيه ضد حكومه رئيس الوزراء
ريشي سوناك اذا حاول تطبيق تشريعا للحد من
الحق في الاضراب محذرا من ثمن سياسي باهض
بحسب تعبيره
المزيد معنا من لندن مصطفى زارو مراسل
العربيه اهلا بك مصطفى اسمح لي ان ابدا
بدايه بقراءه المشهد على الارض تاثير هذه
الاضطرابات على الشارع البريطانيا
حقيقه لم اشهد هذه مثل هكذا اضطرابات
شهيده البلاد عامه
بسبب الاضرابات التي شهدت عده قطاعات
وبالتالي هناك من فضل ان ربما يعمل بالبيت
او حتى اخذ اجازه مطوله خلال هذه الفتره
الثانويه التي عاده ما تكون مزدحمه بالناس
ياتون الى وسط المدينه وايضا يتنقلون من
مدينه الى اخرى ولكن بسبب اضرابات
القطارات ومثلا اليوم لا تزال لضربات
متواصله من طرف هذه المره من طرف
المهندسين الذين يقومون بصيانه همم سكك
الحديد بالاضافه ايضا الى المشرفين على
صيانه الطرق السريعه ايضا هناك ايضا الذين
يقومون باختبارات قياده المركبات هم ايضا
في اضراب لمده يومين غدا ايضا س- س- سيدخل
سائقوه همم
الحافلات في جنوبي وغرب لندن في اضراب
لمده يومين وبالتالي هذه سنه يعني مليئه
بالتقليبات سواء كانت سياسيه او خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالاضطرابات على خلفيه هذه
الاضرابات التي عامه
تعاطي الحكومه مع هذا الملف كيف هو وهل
يمكن ان تصل الى مرحله بالفعل الخروج
بتشريعات يمكن لها ان تحد من اريحيه همم
الاضطرابات بالنسبه للنقابات
الحكومه مصر على ان تواصل بتنفيذ توصيات
اللجنه المستقله لرفع الاجور الذي تقريبا
في حدود 5% على عكس ما يطالب به المضربون
عن العمل في عده قطاعات هناك من يطالب حتى
ب 19% ل ااه لمواجهه غلاء المعيشه وما الى
غير ذلك ولكن الحكومه تقول بان هذا سيؤدي
الى مزيد من التضخم وهذا ما لا تريد ان
تقع فيه هناك اتهامات متبادله بين الحكومه
وايضا بين النقابات واليوم كما ذكرت يعني
الامين العام الجديد الذي استلم مهامه
اليوم همم حذر الحكومه وقال بان ربما سيتم
تنسيق مع نقابات اخرى لتوسيع هذه
الاضطرابات وبالتالي ستكون البلد في شلل
تام على عكس ما شهدناه يعني ولو انه هناك
اضطرابات كبيره لكن ليست بشلل تام في
البلاد ايضا همم ايضا اتهم الحكومه بان
تقوم
الجهود المبذوله للتواصل الى حل مع
الشركات او مدراء الشركات خاصه بما يتعلق
بشركات التي تشغل القطارات وهي 15 الشركه
يعني كانت هناك بعض المفاوضات ولكن يبدو
ان الحكومه غير مرتحابه عن يتم زياده رفع
الاجور باكثر من 11 في المئه تقريبا
مجهول ينتظر العملات المشفره في العام
المقبل بعد ان شهدت اسوا اعوامها على
الاطلاق هذا العام المتابعه
[موسيقى]
طلب رئيس مجلس النواب الليبي عقيل الصالح
رئيس المؤسسه الوطنيه للنف فرحات بن قداره
بعدم صرف او تحويل اي مبلغ او مبالغ ماليه
لاي جهه حتى اعتماد ميزانيه 20 23
فيما اكد التقرير ليبيه ان لجنه التخطيط
والماليه والموازنه العامه بالبرلمان بدات
وضع الرؤيه العامه للانفاق في 20 23
وسياسات الممكن اتباعها لانعاش الاقتصاد
الليبي
وقفه مع ابرز احداث اكتوبر لهذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رئيس الجمهوريه
ايكونومي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الخامسه
[موسيقى]